Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass in unserer 199. Ausgabe. Jaja, reden wir über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wir werden einen Schwerpunkt legen auf dem SC Paderborn und auf dem KSRO SC. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nr. 199. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und ich freue mich sehr, zwei Gäste hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Zum einen Marie, sie ist die Ed Risikso auf Twitter. Sie ist KSC-Fan, vielleicht kennt ihr sie auch schon aus der Saisonvorschau von Melanthoen. Hallo Marie. Sehr schön, dass du hier mit dabei bist. Und ebenso freue ich mich über Marco Kornrumpf, Kornrumpf, Entschuldigung, bitte, vom Padercast, der Edmr Kornrumpf auf Twitter. Da konnte ich es jetzt gleich nochmal üben. Danke dir dafür.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, schön, dass du hier bist. Der Padercast ist ja auch ein Podcast-Urgestein. Unglaublich. Euch gibt es, glaube ich, auch nur irgendwie ein halbes Jahr jünger. Seid ihr, glaube ich, als der Rasenfunk oder so ähnlich? Entschuldigung, älter. Also, Rasenfunk hat angefangen und dann kam aber sehr schnell schon der Padercast und ihr habt uns aber sehr schnell in der Anzahl der Folgen überholt, weil ihr halt durchgeballert habt, wie man heutzutage so schön sagt oder so unschön. Ach Gott, komm, fangen wir lieber an. Das ist ja hier ganz fürchterlich, es ist noch sehr früh, vor allem für den Max. Man merkt es vielleicht. Wie immer, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werden wir es so machen, dass wir bei ein paar Vereine besprechen, jeweils kurz und da einen Überblick geben über den aktuellen Stand. Das sind diejenigen, die im letzten Zweitliga-Kurzpass nicht drangekommen sind. Und dann werden wir ausführlicher über Paderborn und Karlsruhe sprechen. Und wie immer freuen wir uns über Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und der erste Verein, über den wir sprechen wollen, der thront Marie an der Tabellenspitze, der FC St. Pauli, der es geschafft hat, in dieser Spitzengruppe mit drin zu bleiben, die sich so ein bisschen –ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das doch absetzen kann, das glaube ich dann doch nennen –so ganz vorsichtig. Also St. Pauli und Werder haben 51 Punkte. Alle Mannschaften dahinter haben 48, 47, 46, also ein bisschen weniger. Wie würdest du denn jetzt so die letzten Wochen von St. Pauli sehen? Das schien ja zwischendurch durchaus mal ein bisschen zu wackeln.
Ja, ich hatte auch erst gedacht, okay, vielleicht berechnen sie ein, weil die sind ja schon die ganze Saison ziemlich stark dabei gewesen. Und ich dachte, okay. Aber sie haben sich ja anscheinend doch wieder gefangen. Wobei man jetzt ja auch schauen muss, die haben ja glaube ich auch ein ziemlich starkes Restprogramm noch. Die spielen auch gegen Bremen, Darmstadt, Nürnberg und Schalke. Also ich bin gespannt, wie St. Pauli sich da noch so schlagen wird. Aber ich glaube, die sind inzwischen so gefestigt und auch so als Einheit zusammengeworden in der Mannschaft, gerade auch durch die letzten Wochen, dass ich schon denke, dass sie es schaffen werden, ehrlich gesagt.
Die marschieren halt, die sind halt schlecht in die Rückrunde gestartet. Ich meine, wir durften ja relativ früh gegen die spielen, mit einem Unentschieden. Und die haben sich dann aber echt stabilisiert. Und jetzt gegen Heidenheim waren natürlich Big Points nochmal. Ich bin gespannt, ob sie das Tempo durchhalten. Die Mannschaft hat ja letztes Jahr schon sehr viel Courage gezeigt in der Rückrunde. Also, ja, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die bis zum Ende ganz weit oben stehen.
Ja, ich glaube, das Restprogramm wird tatsächlich noch ein Thema werden in der 2. Liga der Männer. Da hat, also St. Pauli hat jetzt den Tabellenstand nach. Man kann es ja so genau nie sagen. Aber das zweitschwerste Restprogramm, noch schwerer ist es nur, ne, Entschuldigung, das drittschwerste, für Nürnberg und Schalke. Also vor allem Schalke hat so einen richtig schönen Mehrklang aus Spielen. Da spielt man gegen Darmstadt auswärts, gegen Werder zu Hause und dann an den letzten beiden Spieltagen St. Pauli zu Hause und Nürnberg auswärts. Also Schalke wird nochmal positiv formuliert alles in der eigenen Hand haben. Und ein bisschen ähnlich ist es aber bei St. Pauli schon auch. Also ihr habt ja schon ein paar der nächsten Gegner genannt. Werder, Darmstadt, Nürnberg, Schalke sind damit dabei. Und mit Düsseldorf und Rostock jetzt vielleicht auch nicht diejenigen Mannschaften, wo noch niemand gestolpert ist in dieser Saison. Also ja, schauen wir mal, wie sich es weiterentwickelt bei St. Pauli. Welchen Eindruck habt ihr denn von Werder Bremen gewonnen? Die haben jetzt dann doch irgendwann mal verloren. Wer hätte das gedacht, dass das überhaupt noch geht unter Ole Werner? Konnte er mal zeigen, ob er auch mit Niederlagen umgehen kann? Er hat es halbwegs verpackt gekriegt, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Seitdem Ole Werner dort unterwegs ist, ist das schon eine ganz starke Nummer. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass sie sich nach dem Markus-Anfang-Debakel und auch nach der Neusortierung Anfang der Saison so schnell dann auch nochmal stabilisieren. Finde ich schon beeindruckend, auch so die Gesamtmannschaftsleistung. Wenn man das jetzt auch am Wochenende nochmal betrachtet, vorne mit Dux und Füllkrug, meiner Meinung nach der gefährlichste Sturm der Liga. Auch da gehe ich ganz stark von aus, dass die bis zum Ende ganz weit oben mitmarschieren. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die noch viel anbrennen lassen.
Marie, würdest du da mitgehen?
Ja, ich habe auch schon in der Winterpause gesagt, dass Bremen mein Aufstiegskandidat Nummer 1 ist. Auch wenn die wirklich schwer reingefunden haben, die 2. Liga, aber klar war es eine Umstellung. Aber wie schon angesprochen wurde, der Sturm ist halt einfach der beste der 2. Liga. Da muss man sich nichts vormachen. Und gerade jetzt nach dem Spiel gegen Darmstadt am Wochenende, ich glaube, das war einfach so ein Schlüsselspiel für beide Mannschaften. Und ja, ich sage mal, Bremen, für die geht es nach oben auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also grundsätzlich kann man ja nichts widersprechen, was ihr gesagt habt, aber welche Rolle, glaubst du denn, Marco, spielen jetzt Verletzungen, wie eben von Ömer Toprak und Marco Friedl? Ich hatte den Eindruck, das war zusätzlich zu der Niederlage der eigentliche Rückschlag, den Werder jetzt erleiden musste in der letzten jüngeren Vergangenheit.
Ich glaube, die sind aber in so einen Pfad gekommen und haben so einen Pace drauf, dass die das kompensieren können. Also ich glaube, das wird die nicht sehr stark stören. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie das Restprogramm dort auch nochmal aussieht, aber jetzt mit Darmstadt. Ich meine, das soll natürlich auch für Werder Bremen nochmal Big Points. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die sich da aus dem Tritt bringen lassen. Vor allen Dingen, man muss ja auch mal sehen, was macht die Konkurrenz. Also ich glaube, dass Darmstadt und St. Pauli sicherlich noch Konkurrenz sind bis zum Schluss, wogegen der HSV und auch Schalke, glaube ich, noch einige Probleme nach vorne bekommen werden. Nürnberg muss man nochmal schauen, aber ich glaube, wenn ich mir die ersten fünf, sechs Plätze anschaue, ist Bremen schon ein direkter Aufstiegskandidat, auch mit Verletzungspech. Ich meine, was natürlich nicht passieren darf, also ich glaube, das würde nochmal rütteln, ist, wenn jetzt Füllkrug oder Duksch sich verletzen und langfristig ausfallen. Da muss man jetzt auch nochmal schauen, wie das sich dann neu sortiert nach der Länderspielpause, die jetzt gerade vor uns steht.
Also ich bin noch so ein bisschen zwiegespalten, was Werder angeht. Allerdings auch jetzt vor dem Hintergrund dieses 1 zu 0s gegen Darmstadt, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, dass man, während es noch Gleichzahl war, bevor Cezula geflogen ist, dass man da schon sehen konnte, Werder fehlen da eben einfach zwei Spieler in der Defensive. Und jetzt hat Werder das gewonnen in Überzahl mit 1 zu 0. Ich bin aber ehrlicherweise noch nicht so komplett überzeugt, lasse mich aber sehr gerne vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Einfach weil ich Darmstadt da auch sehr, sehr stark fand. Jetzt ist Darmstadt, gehört natürlich auch zu den ersten dreien. Also ist schon klar, dass die ja auch mit die beste, eine der besten Mannschaften der zweiten Liga der Männer ist. Aber ich fand Werder da zum ersten Mal mit dem Heidenheim-Spiel zusammen so ein bisschen wackelig.
Ich finde, ich fand die nach vorne hin extrem gefährlich. Das war ja auch ein bisschen unglücklich. Also das 1-0 war schon schmeichelhaft für Darmstadt. Also das hätte ja durchweg auch noch höher ausfallen können. Und ich glaube, ich meine, Klaus-Gasula kennen wir ja sehr gut in Paderborn, der hat ja auch hier gespielt. Ich glaube, das sind dann auch nochmal so Unterschiedsthemen, dass man dann vielleicht nicht das Bein so weit ausfährt, dass man das Knie dort findet. Also es geht auch so ein bisschen um, wie Profi bist du, glaube ich, in Kader? Ich glaube, da ist Bremen extrem gut aufgestellt. Ich glaube, da ist auch Darmstadt und teilweise auch St. Pauli hat da eher unerfahrene Spieler noch am Start. Ich glaube, da kann Werder Bremen auch noch auf der Expertise seines Kaders nochmal aufbauen, unabhängig von der Leistung, die da nochmal besteht. Ich glaube, das macht ganz viel aus, gerade in so einem Endspurt der Saison, wie viel mentale Stärke du da auch mitbringst und wie viel Nerven du auch behalten kannst.
Ja, exzellenter Punkt, finde ich. Aber dann lass doch gleich Marie bei Darmstadt bleiben. Ich hab's ja vorhin schon gesagt, St. Pauli 51 Punkte, Werder 51 Punkte, Darmstadt jetzt nach der Niederlage 48 Punkte. Aber der Knick, der vielleicht von manchen schon befürchtet wurde zu Beginn der Rückrunde, der jetzt nicht so glücklich verlief für Darmstadt, der ist jetzt letztlich offenbar nicht gekommen. Was traust du den Darmstädtern zu und warum? Können sie sie gut mithalten, deiner Meinung nach?
Also ich habe ja bei euch beiden schon gehört, dass ihr von Darmstadt glaube ich viel haltet und auch denkt, dass sie noch sehr lange oben mitspielen werden. Ich bin bei denen ein bisschen Zwiegespalten, so wie du bei Bremen Zwiegespalten bist. Also klar, sie haben einen gut zusammengestellten Kader und auch vom Trainer halte ich sehr viel. Aber meiner Meinung nach fehlt ihnen eben diese Erfahrung, die vielleicht, wie angesprochen wurde, bei Bremen im Kader einfach vorhanden ist. Auch die letzten Spiele haben zwar ihnen einen kleinen Knick gegeben, aber ich glaube, der Knick war jetzt einfach zu stark irgendwo auch, weil es einfach so eng ist in der 2. Liga da oben, dass sie einfach jetzt einfach es nicht mehr schaffen werden, Bremen und St. Pauli einzuholen. Und ich glaube ja einfach, dass sie maximal noch dritter werden können, wenn nicht sogar noch weiter nach hinten rutschen. Weil ich traue es ihnen einfach nicht mehr zu, wieso auch immer. Aber irgendwie, ich bin bei denen richtig Zwiegespalten. Also ich schätze jetzt nicht so stark einen wie ihr beide beispielsweise, glaube ich.
Ich finde, Darmstadt ist so eine Überraschungsmannschaft. Also ich hätte vor der Saison eigentlich nie gedacht, dass Darmstadt so stark oder so lange oben mitspielt. Allein vom Trainer her, Torsten Liebert nicht. Also das ist jetzt auch nicht bekannt dafür, dass der regelmäßig Mannschaften von der zweiten in die erste Liga führt. Dann haben die ja auch relativ viele neue Spieler mit einsortiert. Also der Sturm hat sich ja als extrem stark herausgestellt. Philipp Thietz und Luca Pfeiffer, beides ja auch Ex-Paderborner, hätte ich nie gedacht, dass die sich so etablieren und dort auch so scoren. Ist glaube ich in dieser Spitzengruppe für mich so die Überraschungsmannschaft. Und Marie, gebe ich dir schon recht, also muss man sehen, wie dort dann auch der Endspurt von der Einstellung her und von der Konzentration zu Ende geführt werden kann. Vielleicht eher ein Kandidat, der noch abrutschen könnte.
Bevor ich jetzt hier auch als Darmstadt-Fanclub aus dieser Sendung herausgehe, so ist es ehrlicherweise nicht. Ich dachte, als die 0 zu 4 verloren haben gegen den HSV, dachte ich, jetzt geht es wieder los. Ich habe auch Braunschweig-Fans in meiner Umgebung, die auch gesagt haben, ja, viel Spaß mit einer Thorsten Lieberknecht-Rückrunde, aber so scheint es jetzt nicht zu kommen. Ich glaube, wir alle drei wissen es nicht, ansonsten könnten wir sehr reich werden mit Prognosen, und das ist ja auch das Wunderbare an der 2. Bundesliga der Männer, dass es da eben so eng ist und dass man nicht sagen kann, wer da noch rausfällt. Ich sehe nur schon das Problem, also keine Mannschaft, St. Pauli und Werder sind vielleicht noch am ehesten die Mannschaften, die es schaffen, weiter zu marschieren, wie man immer so schön sagt, also weiter eben einfach konstant ihre Siege zu holen, auch wenn es da auch Rückschläge wahrscheinlich noch geben wird. Und dann, glaube ich, gibt es da eben diese Dreier, vielleicht Vierer-Reihe, muss man schon ein bisschen HSV-freundlich sein, um den HSV da noch mit reinzurechnen, aus Schalke, Nürnberg und Darmstadt eben, die sich dann mutmaßlich erstmal um Rang 3, vielleicht später auch um mehr, da schlagen werden. Und da sehe ich einfach, dass halt sowohl Nürnberg als auch Schalke haben ein Programm, wo sie immer wieder verlieren können. Und da, glaube ich, ist es ein Vorteil, dass Darmstadt eben der Überraschungskandidat ist, dass man einen –im Grunde ist es ja Bremen Leid vom Sturm her. Also es ist auch ein guter Sturm, aber nicht ganz so gut wie der sehr gute Sturm von Werder Bremen. Er ist dann wahrscheinlich der Zweitbeste, würde ich sagen, einfach nur von den Einzelspielern her. Und das ist schon sehr, sehr viel wert. Und gleichzeitig habe ich jetzt noch nachgeguckt, weil wir schon über so Themen wie Erfahrung in den letzten Spielen und Nervosität gesprochen haben. Kleiner Fun-Fact dazu bei Werder Bremen, wo wir alle drei gesagt haben, Mensch, die haben so viel Erfahrung im Kader, die wackeln bestimmt nicht. Zweitjüngstes Team der Liga im Durchschnitt. Darmstadt 98, drittjüngstes Team der Liga im Durchschnitt. Man muss natürlich gucken, wer da spielt. Also Flo Zengler würde uns jetzt wahrscheinlich dann die Spielminuten nach Alter aufgeteilt aufdröseln und zeigen. Ganz so ist es von den Einsatzzeiten dann nicht. Aber fand ich jetzt gerade lustig, als ich es gesehen habe.
Ich finde, ich meine, das haben wir auch schon öfters diskutiert. Es ist ja einmal die Spielminuten oder das Alter, was du auf dem Platz hast. Das ist aber auch das Alter, was du neben dem Platz hast oder auf der Bank hast oder in der Kabine hast. Es gibt ja immer wieder so Anker-Spieler, die du brauchst, die dann auch, wenn sie vielleicht nicht auf dem Platz stehen, trotzdem motivieren und den Kader konzentriert halten. Das ist, glaube ich, auch sehr, sehr wichtig. Ich glaube, dass das auch Unterschiedsspieler sind, die du gar nicht auf dem Platz wahrnimmst, aber die die Mannschaft extrem brauchen und auch voranbringen. Gerade in so einer extrem nervenaufreibenden Schlussphase der Saison.
Ja, das ist definitiv richtig. Und das trifft ja auch zu auf den FC Schalke 04, wo wir noch einmal einen Trainerwechsel gesehen haben, Marie. Nach einem für neutrale Beobachterinnen und Beobachter fantastischen 3 zu 4 gegen Hansel Rostock, aber eben für Schalke 04 natürlich dramatisch. Also ich möchte mich da jetzt nicht drüber lustig machen. Es war einfach nur ein absolut faszinierendes Spiel für jeden, der das gesehen hat. Wurde Demetrios Gramozis entlassen? Mike Büskens hat übernommen und auch erst mal mit 3 zu 0 gegen Ingolstadt und dann 2 zu 1 gegen Hannover 2 Siege einfahren können. Hat dich dieser dann doch relativ später Trainerwechsel überrascht?
Nee, er hat mich so gar nicht überrascht. Ich fand Schalke gegen uns damals, das war ein paar Spiele vor, ich weiß, es gab ein Spiel direkt davor, aber schon sehr bescheiden von der Leistung her. Ich fand uns schon nicht gut, aber Schalke war dann nochmal ein gleiches Niveau oder vielleicht sogar ein Tacken schlechter. Gerade wenn man sich mal so anschaut, was die für eine Qualität im Kader haben könnten, hat mich das gar nicht überrascht. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt schon eher davor mitgerechnet mit einem Trainerwechsel, weil Schalke ja auch aufsteigen möchte. Das ist ja ein ganz klares Ziel. Und bei Schalke hat es mich immer gewundert, dass die überhaupt noch da oben mit so dran sind. Weil ich fand die von den ganzen Leistungen in der Saison bisher eigentlich nicht so gut, aber wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun, dass andere Vereine auch öfters mal gepatzt haben. Und Schalke hat halt nur mal einfach der Rote. Da ist halt nur mal ein Unterscheidspieler in der 2. Liga. Der schießt dann seine Tore und dann punkten sie am Ende doch noch oder gewinnen sogar. Und ich glaube, der Trainerwechsel hat ihm jetzt noch mal sehr viel Aufschwung gebracht, was ich jetzt auch im Umfeld gehört habe von den Leuten, die ich bei Schalke so ein bisschen kenne und mit denen ich zu tun habe. Die sind da jetzt seit dem Trainerwechsel wieder wirklich optimistisch, dass es noch klappen könnte. Und manchmal braucht man auch so einen Trainerwechsel, um einfach nur einen Schwung noch mal reinzubekommen. Aber ich bin gespannt, wie du ja schon angesprochen hast, Schalke hat ja auch ein sehr starkes Restprogramm noch. Aber, ja, mal schauen, was sie draus machen.
Also ist so ein bisschen, also ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also ich würde sowas nicht tun. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob der Büskins jetzt die Impulse bringt, die man da noch braucht. Ich glaube einfach, dass der Kader mal wieder in Summe nicht passt. Also der, ich weiß nicht, also wenn ich das zum Beispiel vergleiche mit dem HSV oder auch mit Werder Bremen, ich meine, man hat sich da mit Ter Rodde vorne jemand eingekauft, der natürlich ein Torgarant ist. Man hat mit einem Bülter jemanden, der wirklich ganz gut ist. Ein Salazar ist natürlich für die 2. Liga echt viel zu schade. Aber ich glaube, die Komposition in Summe ist nicht Zweigligatauglich, dass du damit einfach durchmarschieren kannst. Und ich glaube, dass Schalke in Summe so ein bisschen unterschätzt hat, wie schwer die 2. Liga ist, auch bei den vermeintlich schwacheren, schwächeren Mannschaften, siehe Rostock. Ich glaube, dass das so ein bisschen auch an dem Spielermaterial liegt und was dort auch so an mentalem Mindset vertreten ist bei Schalke, dass das nicht funktioniert. Und ich glaube nicht, dass Büsskins jetzt den Unterschied macht, sodass die jetzt anfangen zu marschieren.
Ach, diese Trainerwechsel und gerade auf Schalke, ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, mich da immer zu wiederholen. Also Schalke ist verzweifelt, Schalke braucht den direkten Wiederaufstieg. Und das kann man nicht kleinreden. Also ich kann auch verstehen, dass man da auch, also man muss alles tun, wo man als Sportlicher, Verantwortlicher glaubt, das könnte uns irgendwie in die erste Liga zurückkiefen. Und vor diesem Hintergrund und auch vor dem, wie Schalke die Saison sonst so gespielt hat, fand ich das auch nicht überraschend und konnte diesen Trainerwechsel auch nachvollziehen. De facto bedeutet es aber, wenn man sich mal klarmacht, wenn man das Zwei-Jahres-Fenster kurz betrachtet, dann ist es der sechste Trainerwechsel. Und man muss sagen, man hat sich ja dann in der letzten Erstligasaison auf Gramozis festgelegt und da ja auch schon darauf festgelegt, mit dir wollen wir den Wiederaufstieg in der zweiten Liga schaffen. Wir richten jetzt mit dir gemeinsam den Kader, die Spielweise und so weiter daraufhin aus. Und dann müsste man, glaube ich, das Fazit ziehen, dass es jetzt dann der sechste Trainerwechsel der stattgefunden hat, weil man kein gutes Scouting beim Trainer betrieben hat. Oder vielleicht aus verschiedenen Gründen, sicherlich auch finanziellen Gründen, nicht in der Lage war, das durchzuziehen. Und das Problem jenseits aller Witze, die man darüber machen kann, was sehr einfach ist, das Problem ist nicht nur, dass du irgendwie 1000 Trainer auf der Abfindungsliste hast, sondern weil das halt so eine Spirale auslöst. Was kommt denn jetzt nach Mike Biskens? Was käme denn jetzt, wenn der Aufstieg gelänge? Wann startest du dann da rein, dann den Klassenerhalt für die 1. Liga anzugehen, sportlich, finanziell, personell und genauso aber auch im Misserfolgspfahl? Wie richtest du dich dann für die nächste Saison aus, wo es ja ganz, ganz schlimme Einschnitte im Kader wird geben? Und in dieser Spirale befindet sich Schalke und ich erzähle da jetzt auch nichts Neues, deswegen habe ich so das Gefühl, irgendwie so Phrasen von mir zu geben und trotzdem ist es aber ein unbestreitbarer Fakt und in so einem Kontext finde ich dann, also es gibt immer Gründe, jemandem wie Gramozis, es gab gute Gründe, ihn zu entlassen. Ich glaube aber, Schalke muss aus dieser Spirale raus und das wird aber halt wehtun. Du kommst aus dieser Spirale ganz, ganz selten mit der Pellegrino-Matarazzo-Lösung raus oder mit der Bo-Svenzon-Lösung. Das funktioniert halt einfach sehr selten. In der Regel tut das richtig weh, mal an jemanden festzuhalten, den ganzen Verein ein bisschen auf ein moderneres Level auch zu heben und dann es entweder mit dem zu schaffen oder mit einem Nachfolger, der dann in dessen Geist handelt.
Ich meine, wenn du es vergleichst, auch vielleicht mit der Tabellenspitze oben oder mit Traditionsvereinen aus der ersten Liga, die aber nicht mehr aus der zweiten Liga rauskommen, guck dir den HSV an. Da dreht sich das Trainerkarussell auch sehr regelmäßig. Ich weiß nicht, ob das im Sinne des Erfinders ist, dass diese Trainerrotation wirklich einen Mehrwert bringt. Ich glaube, solche Vereine wie Timo Schulz von St. Pauli, Heidenheim, wo an den Trainern festgehalten wird, wo lange Jahre gearbeitet wird, nach und nach ein Kader zusammengebaut wird, der dann wirklich mal oben mitspielen kann. Ich glaube, das ist die bessere Lösung für einen Zweitlegerverein. Ich weiß, Schalke hat Druck und muss sich hochkatapultieren. Aber der HSV hat das schon gezeigt, dass einfach nur Geld reinstecken und zweimal den Trainer wechseln, das führt eher zum Klassenerhalt.
Marie, kann man da Parallelen ziehen zum KSC vor jetzt ja dann doch schon einigen Jahren nach dem Abstieg?
Ja, also etwas schon. Also ich glaube, bei uns war es ja auch eine Zeit lang wirklich sehr, sehr turbulent, sei es Trainerwechsel, sei es innerhalb der Mannschaft. Es war so eine Unruhe drin. Es wurde aber immer schlimmer einfach dadurch. Also man hat sich selber zu hohe Ziele gesetzt, man war selber zu sehr überzeugt auch von dem, was man hat, wie bei Schalke jetzt meiner Meinung nach auch. Ich glaube, die sollten erstmal wirklich nüchtern betrachten, wie der Kader aufgebaut ist, wo sie stehen, dass vielleicht der direkte Wiederaufstieg eben nicht das Richtige ist oder das Ziel, was man anstreben sollte. Und das war bei uns damals halt auch so. Man hat gesehen, am Ende sind wir dann die Drittliga sogar abgerutscht, weil einfach nichts mehr wirklich gepasst hat. Der Kader war schlecht zusammengestellt, die ganze Zeit Trainerwechsel. Und ja, da war, glaube ich, Christian Eichner der Glücksfall, der uns passieren konnte. Und alles, wie es auch jetzt im Verein ist. Aber Schalke hat da bis dahin noch einen sehr langen Weg, glaube ich, zu gehen. Und ich sage immer, ein Trainerwechsel zeigt dann eher die Verzweiflung vom Verein. Wenn sonst nichts anderes mehr klappt, muss halt der Trainer am Ende gehen. Aber sie sind irgendwo auch selber schuld, dass es soweit aktuell gekommen ist. Man kann zwar ihnen nur das Beste wünschen, aber am Ende ist es halt wieder Schalke.
Ja, und das darf ja niemanden mehr als die Schalker höchstpersönlich. Das ist ja sowieso unbestritten. Jeder würde irgendwie erfolgreich arbeiten und man wäre auch gerne Fan eines Vereins, der nicht immer in Muster zurückfällt, die man überall schon kennt. Also das ist die Situation bei Schalke 04. Da wird es sehr, sehr, sehr interessant, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Die Frage ist, wie interessant wird noch die Saison des SC Paderborn, lieber Marco, über die wir jetzt sprechen wollen? Ich sehe einen 8. Tabellenplatz, ich sehe 37 Punkte. Das sind 11 Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz und es sind gleichzeitig 9 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz zum Abstieg in die 3. Liga. Saison also im Grunde schon vorbei?
Ja, ich glaube, das fasst das ganz gut zusammen. Spätestens nach dem Auswärtsspiel in Regensburg, das wir verloren haben, ist das Thema Mittelmaß besiegelt. Nach oben wird wohl nichts mehr gehen, nach unten auch nichts mehr. Das würde mich wundern. Von daher ist die Saison vorbei. Es gibt auch schon die ersten Verpflichtungen oder eine Verpflichtung, die wurde letzte Woche sogar schon angekündigt. Man beschäftigt sich scheinbar jetzt schon damit, den neuen Kader zusammenzubauen. Ich glaube, die Rückrunde oder auch das Ende der Hinrunde ist für uns schon die Luft ausgegangen. Wir haben den Anschluss ganz klar verloren. Das hat einige Faktoren. Ich meine, ihr habt ja schon mal diskutiert, das Thema Sven Michel. Aber auch die gesamte Corona-Situation im Verein hat da das eine oder andere zugetragen. Zumindest ist das meine persönliche Meinung. Es lässt sich auch ganz gut belegen an Tabellenständen und Punkte gewinnen. Ja, ist leider schade. Gerade nach den Verstärkungen in der Winterpause hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass man noch versucht, oben anzugreifen. Sven Michel hin oder her, bin ich momentan ein wenig enttäuscht von der Leistung. Ich glaube, da kann der Kader mehr als das, was man gerade zeigt.
Und wie würde dann dein Zwischenfazit, ich finde, für einen Gesamtfazit sollte man ihm doch eine ganze Saison geben von Lukas Kwasniok ausfallen. Wir haben Steffen Baumgart zum 1. FC Köln gewechselt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben. Soll ganz gut laufen für ihn da beim FC. Lukas Kwasniok hatte große Fußstapfen, in die er treten musste. Und wir haben hier schon ein paar Mal über ihn geredet. Da wurde gesagt von den Gästen, die hier zu Gast waren, dass er einen ähnlichen Fußball spielen lässt, wie Baumgart ähnlich auch in den Automatismen und Abläufen. Und ihm wurde eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeugnis ausgestellt. Wie siehst du es?
Also erstmal, Steffen Baumgart war natürlich ein Argerverlust für Paderborn. Lukas Kwasniok spielt in der Tat einen sehr offensiven, angriffsorientierten Fußball. Wenn man sich das aber näher anschaut, also wir machen ja beim Padercast auch so eine Taktikrunde neuerdings, ist es schon sehr differenziert zu dem, was Steffen Baumgart macht. Also ich verfolge Steffen Baumgart jetzt nicht mehr beim FC, aber im Paderborn hat er wenig variationsreich und variantenreich gespielt, also kleinere Anpassungen vorgenommen. Lukas Kwasniok hat da einen anderen Ansatz. Also ich glaube, wir hatten ein-, zweimal in dieser Saison eine Aufstellung, die sich mit der vom vorherigen Spiel gedeckt hat. Also er macht taktisch eigentlich sehr, sehr viele Umstellungen. Eigentlich jedes Spiel merkt man, gerade in der Offensive, im Aufbauspiel, lässt er andere Formationen, Grundformationen spielen. Also er ist viel variabler in dem, wie er spielt. Ob das jetzt gut ist oder schlecht ist, weiß ich gar nicht. Da spricht glaube ich der Tabellenplatz schon für sich. Ich glaube, taktisch ist Lukas Kwasniok eine gute Nachfolge für Steffen Baumgart. Ich glaube, was Steffen Baumgart im Paderborn gezeigt hat, ist, dass er ein großer Motivator ist. Er hat sehr wenig, sehr viel gemacht und hat das auch sehr beeindruckend umgesetzt. Das ist etwas, was Lukas Kwasniok nicht so mitbringt. Ich glaube, dass er ein großer Taktiker ist. Auch der Trainerstarb, wenn man den Eddie Schmidt zum Beispiel sieht, der bei uns die Videoanalyse macht, da ist viel Taktikfinesse unterwegs. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, dass es Probleme gibt, die Mannschaft zu erreichen. Wenn ich jetzt so betrachte, wo wir jetzt stehen, wenn ich so sehe, die PK nach Regensburg, da habe ich auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass da ein bisschen Resignation beim Lukas Kwasniok aufkommt. Vielleicht auch ein Stück weit, dass er die Mannschaft nicht erreicht. Die Mannschaft vielleicht auch ein Stück weit überfordert mit der Variation, die er gerne in ein Spiel reinbringen möchte. Er selber sagt, der Kader bringt einfach nicht mehr zum Tabellenplatz. Also nicht so negativ gesehen. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob er den Kader vielleicht auch überfordert. Er hat natürlich das Problem gehabt, dass gerade nach der Hinrunde das Spiel sehr stark auf Sven Michel ausgerichtet war. Da gab es ja hier auch mal im Kurzpass die Diskussion, ob Paderborn sich da ein Gefallen getan hat, dass man Sven Michel verkauft hat. Vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Hintergrund dazu. Das war das dritte Mal, dass Union Berlin versucht hat, Sven Michel zu kaufen. Ich glaube, die Aussage von Sven Michel war sehr klar, was denn jetzt die Marschrichtung ist. Ich glaube, da gab es keine Diskussion. Und wenn man sieht, dass Sven Michel eigentlich die Saison seines Lebens, zumindest in Paderborn gespielt hat, ich glaube, das kann man nicht vergleichen mit dem, was er vorher gemacht hat. Und wenn man sein Alter dabei heran zieht, und Paderborn ist halt ein Verein, der auch davon lebt, Leistungsträger zu verkaufen, auch wenn es kleines Geld ist, wenn man einen Vergleich herbeizieht zu Transfersummen, die in anderen Vereinen getätigt werden, ist es glaube ich essentiell für Paderborn und eigentlich lebensnotwendig, dass man so einen Spieler in so einer Situation abgibt. Nichtsdestotrotz ist dadurch halt viel weggebrochen. In der Winterpause haben wir uns mit Muslia aus Hannover und Philipp Lehmann als Laie aus Stuttgart extrem im Mittelfeld verstärkt. Clement ist jetzt schon seit drei Spielen leider verletzt mit einem Muskelfaseriss. Muslia war am Anfang sehr positiv, ist momentan ein bisschen die Luft raus wie im gesamten Kader. Lucas Kwasniok hat es da auch nicht geschafft, das Spiel von Sven Michel auf den Rest des Kaders zu übertragen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er der Richtige ist für Paderborn. Er hat ja noch einen Vertrag. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob man diesen Vertrag weiterlaufen lässt oder ob man dort vielleicht in eine andere Richtung geht und sich vielleicht noch einen anderen Impuls von außen wünscht. Gerade weil sich im Dezember letzten Jahres nach außen schon eine Diskrepanz zwischen Verein und Trainer bezüglich der Corona- und Impfstatusdiskussion manifestierte. Das Thema ist zwar jetzt offiziell vom Tisch, aber ich glaube, dass das auch gerade in so einer Entscheidung, ob man weiter zusammenarbeiten möchte, eine gewichtige Rolle spielen wird. Jetzt zur Sommerpause.
Was heißt denn offiziell vom Tisch? Ist Lukas Kwasniok jetzt geimpft? Er war ja der letzte Trainer in den ersten beiden Männerprofiligen, der noch ungeimpft war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Lukas jetzt geimpft ist. Er ist ja nicht auskunftpflichtig, ich habe nichts dazu gehört. Er trägt keine Maske mehr, ist ja jetzt auch nicht mehr notwendig aufgrund der Hygienebestimmung. Ich gehe persönlich davon aus, dass er es nicht ist. Wieso sollte er es tun? Er hat ja auch selber ganz klar sich positioniert, dass er gesagt hat, wenn es notwendig ist und Rechtsmittel gibt, die das verlangen, dann würde er es auch tun. Aber jetzt so selbst motiviert, sieht er keine Motivation dazu, sich impfen zu lassen. Kann ich so nicht sagen. Aber die Situation an sich, weil der SCP hat sich schon sehr stark pro Impfen ausgesprochen, was ich sehr positiv fand. Er hat auch einige Aktionen gefahren, im Impfen in der Kabine, im Stadion. Und dann aber auf der anderen Seite einen Trainer zu haben, der sich offensichtlich nicht bereit erklärt. Ich meine, das hört sich ein bisschen doof an, aber das bricht so ein bisschen mit der Corporate Identity. Wenn ich in einem Unternehmen arbeite, sei es ein Fußballverein, versuche ich mich auch an der Corporate Identity dieses Unternehmens zu orientieren und da anzupassen. Ich glaube, dass das schon einen starken Bruch gegeben hat in Vereinen, der nicht nach außen getragen worden ist. Der aber sicherlich schwer im Magen noch liegt.
Ich meine, es ist insofern ein schwieriges Thema, weil es natürlich seine persönliche Entscheidung eigentlich ist und es uns das eigentlich auch nicht angeht. Jetzt hatten wir aber ganz lange Impfen als Fremdschutz. Da hat es dann eben doch eine gesellschaftliche Relevanz. Allerdings muss man auch so ehrlich sein, hat sich das Virus so verwandelt, dass jetzt Impfen dann doch wieder zum Selbstschutz wird. Also die Fremdschutzwirkung, die ist jetzt marginaler auf Grundhospitalisierungsraten, Todesraten usw. Möchte ich jetzt nicht ins Detail reingehen, aber deswegen eiern wir natürlich da auch so ein bisschen drum rum. Ich habe die Frage auch irgendwie so ein bisschen ungern gestellt, weil eigentlich geht es mich nicht an, ob jemand anderes geimpft ist. Allerdings waren wir eben in einer Situation, in der es dann doch eben den anderen etwas anging. Und in dieser Situation hinein hat er sich dagegen entschieden. Und ich glaube, da ist ja dann auch quasi die Vorbildwirkung oder auch die Außenwirkung auf die eigene Mannschaft dann ein Thema, was man nicht negieren kann. Also es werden nicht auch alle Spieler ungeimpft sein, sondern da wird es wahrscheinlich auch ein Auseinandergehen geben. Und weil eben die Impfung mit Themen wie Solidarität, mit Themen wie Rücksichtnahme auf andere verbunden ist, steckt da mehr drin, glaube ich, als eben nur der Pieks. Und deshalb bin ich auch gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Ich würde ganz gerne Marie an der Stelle mal reinholen. Denn Lukas Kwasniok war ja U19-Trainer, unter anderem, vorher schon U17, beim KSC. Ich habe schon vorhin als Schmidt erwähnt wurde als Co-Trainer oder Spielanalyst, habe ich schon ganz hektisch gegoogelt, ob das der Euro-Eddie ist. Ist er aber leider nicht. Er ist natürlich viel, viel jünger, weil Lukas Kwasniok ist ja auch sehr jung. Überrascht dich das, was du jetzt hörst von Kwasniok bei Paderborn?
Also gerade wenn es um die Spielweise geht, wenn es heißt, dass er offensiv schon ziemlich spielt, bin ich schon sehr überrascht, weil bei uns, okay, man muss die Umstände beachten, wir waren damals im tabellen Keller, dann war er kurz Interimstrainer bei uns und da war einfach so die Hauptsache, okay, Hauptsache wir spielen 0-0, klar im Abstiegskampf, aber das war dann eher auch so eine Art Aufgeben, so okay, wir probieren es gar nicht mehr, offensiv zu spielen, sondern wir stellen uns einfach hinten rein und probieren, eine Schadensbegrenzung zu betreiben. Und wenn ich jetzt dann höre, so Offensivfußball von Kwasniok und so, denke ich mir so, hm, wie passt das zusammen? Ich musste gerade auch kurz schmunzeln, als ich das alles gehört habe, aber ich glaube, so dieses, was dann auch angesprochen wird, ist so, ja, jetzt hat man sich auch schon so ein bisschen die Saison abgehakt als Paderborn hat dann wieder so zu ihm gepasst, wo er bei uns dann auch einfach gesagt hat, okay, wir haben keine Chance mehr auf dem Platz, wir spielen jetzt einfach noch die Saison zu Ende und ja, dann mal gucken. Also, ja, meine Meinung ist, Quasenock ist jetzt eh nicht so positiv, aber ja, wenn er bei Paderborn dann reingepasst hat und so, naja, geht jetzt da so, nachdem was ich gehört habe, ich dachte, das wäre positiver, aber ja, vielleicht kann er dann doch Offensiv-Fußball auch spielen.
Also, ich habe Lukas ja mal kennenlernen dürfen. Wir hatten auch eine Padercast-Folge vor der Saison, wo wir mit Lukas schon mal gesprochen haben. Also, menschlich ist das ein Top-Typ, ne? Also, ich fand den total nett, offen, umgänglich, sehr freundlich, witzig. Also, da möchte ich ihm irgendwie auch nichts nachsagen. Also, von daher, das passt schon. Was du jetzt so sagst vom KSC oder seine Zeit beim KSC, ich meine, das lässt sich auch ein bisschen auf Saarbrücken übertragen. Also, Saarbrücken, letztes Jahr, dritte Liga, war ja Aufsteiger und stand da ja auch kurzzeitig mal auf den Tabellen ersten. Und hat dann aber, ich glaube, in der Rückrunde ging dann auch so ein bisschen die Luft aus. Für Saarbrücken vielleicht jetzt auch nicht so überraschend als Aufsteiger, ein Durchmarsch ist da ja eher unrealistisch. Aber dann kam ja auch die Aussage, dass er nur bleibt, wenn es zum Aufstieg hingeht. Also hat er ja auch eine klare Linie gezogen. Und ja, dann ist ja Saarbrücken schon stark abgefallen. Also dieses, was du sagst, so am Ball bleiben, bis zum Ende dranbleiben, wenn das beim KSC schon war. Bei Saarbrücken war es auf alle Fälle auch so. Und bei Paderborn sieht es momentan auch so ein bisschen aus. Das ist jetzt nicht die beste Eigenschaft für einen Trainer, glaube ich.
es zeigt auch, warum es nicht 30 Jürgen Klops da draußen gibt. Weil es eben mehr ist als nur Taktik, weil es mehr ist als Dinge, die man in Büchern lernen kann und die man in der Fußballlehrerausbildung lernt. Das alles ist nicht unwichtig. Und ich würde die These aufstellen, dass es kaum noch möglich ist, in längerer Zeit im deutschen Profifußball tätig zu sein, ohne quasi die Basis an Training, Taktik, Analyse zu haben. Weil diese Verwissenschaftlichung des Fußballs ist inzwischen bei allen Vereinen eingekehrt. Darunter fällt man nicht mehr zurück. Aber eben die Zusatzaufgaben, die man hat in der Darstellung nach außen, in der Menschenführung, im psychologischen Verständnis. Auch da fand ich ganz interessant, was Timo Schulz im Millanturn damals in deren Projekt erzählt hat. In dem Bereich hat er auch gesagt, da war die Fußball-Lehrerausbildung für ihn am einfachsten. Das wusste er alles schon. Da hat er auch 1-0 oder so was sich abgeholt an Note. Weil das so sein Thema war. Auch selbst das würde es noch nicht bedeuten, dass er deswegen gut der Trainer ist. Man muss es immer noch umsetzen können. Aber das sind alles Faktoren, die kommen mit dazu. Das finde ich spannend, dass an so einem Fall von außen betrachtet, mit aller Vorsicht, wir sitzen nicht in der Kabine, aber dann schon das Gefühl zu haben, naja, hier gibt es offenbar eben, da fehlt ein gewisser Bereich, der quasi die richtig guten Trainer von den gut ausgebildeten Trainern unterscheidet. Und dieser Bereich kann aber auch noch kommen. Das ist dann quasi so die nächste Wolke, die man da nehmen kann. Also man lese sich einfach mal Berichte durch über Job Heinkes bei seinen frühen Trainerstationen. Und dann erinnert man sich nochmal, wie er beim FC Bayern verabschiedet wurde. Und was da auch gesagt wurde, wie er sich zum Beispiel weiterentwickelt hat im Umgang der Spieler in einem sehr hohen Alter. Also auch ganz kontraintuitiv zu dem, wie wir es in unserer Gesellschaft immer so erleben, dass ja die Alten sich angeblich gar nicht mehr verändern können. Also das kann auch kommen, kann auch sein, dass wir irgendwie in 20 Jahren über Lukas Kwasniok reden. Und er hat noch ein paar Elemente verändert in seinem Trainerdasein. Vielleicht auch in seiner Persönlichkeit, weiß ich nicht, geht mich nix an. Aber ja, deswegen finde ich diese Diskussion spannend. Auch weil ich auch schon mal Kontakt mit ihm hatte, da war er auch sehr nett. Wäre er nicht zu Jena gewechselt, verdammt, dann hätte er keine Zeit mehr.
Ja gut, das Jena-Kapitel war glaube ich auch, das sagt er ja selber, da war ja Sportdirektor und Trainer im EIM, das war viel zu viel. Also ich glaube, das kann man ausklammern.
Ja, danach wollte ich ihn dann auch nicht mehr anfragen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das ist glaube ich. Aber du hast schon recht, dieses lifelong learning ist schon ein wichtiger Aspekt. Ich glaube, da trennt sich auch die Spreu vom Weizen, wo man dann so selbst reflektiert ist, nochmal zurückzublicken und darüber nachzudenken, was man besser machen kann nach vorne hin. Ich glaube, gerade in so einer Arbeit als Trainer von Fußballern, wo du halt glaube ich durch Motivation, durch individuelles Eingehen auf die Persönlichkeit viel erreichen kannst. Wir hatten ja vorhin von Baumgart gesprochen. Guckt euch an, was Steffen Baumgart mit Anthony Modest gemacht hat. Das ist ja kein anderer Modest als letztes Jahr. Ganz im Gegenteil, er ist ja ein Jahr älter geworden. Und wie durchschlagend er unterwegs ist. Mit Motivation, Worten kann man viel mehr erreichen, glaube ich, als mit Sondertrainingsschichten.
Pädagogik. Ich kann es euch sagen, ich wohne in unmittelbarer Nähe zur Säbener Straße. Da ist eine 30er-Zone. Und ich kann euch am Pfahlverhalten mancher Bayern-Profis, da erkenne ich Parallelen zu manchen Eigenschaften auf dem Platz. Und da denke ich mir so, ja, gut, wundert mich jetzt nicht, aber da brauchst du auch einen sehr, sehr guten Trainer, der dich aber zur Seite nimmt und sagt, du Junge, manchmal blitzen die hier und auch so. Generell wirkt das jetzt nicht so gut, weil man erkennt euch sehr gut an euren Nummernschildern. Die sind beim Echtzubeil nämlich einheitlich. So, anderes Thema. Lasst uns über den KSC sprechen. Marie sitzt wahrscheinlich schon auf heißen Kohlen. Ein bisschen konnten wir ja auch schon die Brücke bauen. Also wir haben beim ST Paderborn eine abgeschlossene Saison. Ist es beim KSC denn genauso, Marie?
Ja, also ich glaube, unser Ziel ist eigentlich auch nur ganz klar, noch die 40 Punkte sozusagen erstmal voll zu machen und dann einfach die Saison ausklingen zu lassen, also Klassenerhalt sichern und dann einfach mal schauen, was die Saison noch so bringt, sei es nach oben, sei es nach unten. Hauptsache dann hat er einen Klassenerhalt. Ich meine, man sieht es ja auch am Tabellenstand. Ich glaube, es sind zwei Tore Unterschied von Paderborn, Punkt gleich, sonst und alles.
Es war eine sehr enge Kiste, wer hier zuerst drankommt.
So offen kann ich das sagen. Also ich glaube, erstmal bin ich ganz froh, kann ich noch nachtragen zu Michel, dass er gewechselt ist nach dem Spiel gegen euch, gegen Paderborn, wo er seinen Hitschrick da gemacht hat. Also ich zum Beispiel war dann ganz froh, als ich gelesen habe, dass er weg ist jetzt fürs Rückspielen. Aber ja, also bei uns ist jetzt auch einfach nur Klassenerhalt und dann ist man glaube ich auch erstmal zufrieden, hat dann wieder eine solide Saison gespielt, hatte keine Turbulenzen richtig drin, sondern hat einfach ja es runtergespielt und mehr will man glaube ich aktuell beim KSC auch erstmal nicht.
Ja, das sind so glaube ich die unterschiedlichen Welten, aus denen diese beiden Vereine kommen, obwohl sie sich so häufig in den Ligen dann doch irgendwie getroffen haben, aber das lag halt am SCP, man muss ja jetzt nicht nochmal sagen. Da ging es ja rauf und runter in einem fröhlichen Hin und Her. Beim KSC ging es jetzt eben zuletzt eher rauf. Und du hast schon vorhin Christian Eichner da als den entscheidenden Mann genannt. Was hat er denn zum KSC gebracht, was vorher gefehlt hat?
Alles glaube ich einfach, ehrlich gesagt. Also wie gesagt, ich kann mich selber als komplettes Christian Eichner-Fangirl outen, aber auch schon das Zwischenmenschliche, was wir angesprochen haben, das ist etwas einfach, was Christian Eichner mitbringt, auch wenn er jetzt wirklich noch ein junger Trainer ist und nicht so viel Vorerfahrung hatte jetzt, gerade auch als Chef-Trainer. Er ist ja die erste Station mit uns als Chef-Trainer, aber wenn man einfach sieht, was er aus der Mannschaft rausholt, sei es leistungstechnisch, sei es aber auch zwischenmenschlich, er weiß genau, wie er jeden Spieler anzugehen hat, er weiß genau, was er machen muss. Ich glaube, er ist das Beispielweise Spiel in Aue am Wochenende. Wir haben so eine schlechte erste Halbzeit gespielt, also wirklich grottenschlecht, und das hat er denen auch in der Halbzeit dann gesagt, den Spielern, aber hat gleichzeitig auch gesagt dann, ja, was Positives, wir liegen zum ersten Mal nicht zurück in Aue zur Halbzeit. Und es hat auch wirklich dann so positiv deklariert, und kaum hat er das angesprochen, war die zweite Halbzeit halt komplett anders. Plötzlich, klar, sie war jetzt auch nicht brauschen, aber wir haben am Ende 3-0 gewonnen, ich weiß nicht, wann wir das letzte Mal in Aue 3-0 gewonnen haben. Und sei es jetzt ein junger Spieler wie ein Breithaupt bei uns, sei es ein alter, erfahrener Spieler wie ein Gondorf, er weiß halt genau, wie er jeden Spieler anzugehen hat, er weiß genau, wie er die Mannschaft aufzustellen hat, wie er sie einzustellen hat, auch wenn es mal nicht so läuft. Es gibt niemanden, der dann an Christian Eichner zweifelt, sondern der ist so gefestigt inzwischen bei uns. Und gerade, wenn man sich die letzten Jahre bei uns anschaut, wir hatten ziemlich viele Trainerwechsel. Und jetzt Christian Eichner ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren bei uns. Er ist das Beste, was uns passieren konnte. Es ist eine Ruhe in den Verein eingekehrt. Vorher war es ja alles total durcheinander. Drittliga-Abstieg, dann wieder Aufstieg, dann wieder Drittliga-Abstieg. Ich glaube, die letzten zwei Jahre war jetzt wirklich mal sehr, sehr entspannt als KSC-Fan, was man bei uns einfach auch nicht kannte. Wir hoffen einfach, dass Christian eigentlich noch sehr lange bei uns bleibt, aber ich prophezeihe ihm auch eine sehr große Trainer-Karriere aktuell. Er hat alles, was man eigentlich mitbringen muss, sei es, wie gesagt, das Spielverständnis, sei es das Zwischenmenschliche, also aus dem kann noch gut was werden. Ich glaube, bei ihm spielt es halt einfach mit, dass er selber Spieler schon war. Er weiß, wie es ist, Spieler zu sein. Er war ja auch bei uns Spieler, was immer halt auch sehr in die Karten spielt. Er kennt den Verein. Aber wie gesagt, ich bin einfach Christian Eichner Fan.
Es ist so ganz subtil zwischen den Zeilen. Konnte man das herauslesen, wenn man ganz genau hingehört hat. Erklär, erzähl uns doch noch mal so ein bisschen, weil ich vermute, dass das jetzt nicht alle Hörerinnen und Hörer noch so genau vor Augen haben, wie die letzten drei Jahre vom KSC verlaufen sind. Weil irgendwann sind sie einfach aus dem Blickfeld rausgerutscht. Ehrlicherweise mit dem Abstieg in die dritte Liga. Da hört es eben dann einfach bei vielen Fußballfans auf. Welcher Situation kam denn dann eigentlich Christian Eichner? Und was hat sich überhaupt beim KSC verändert, dass man vier Trainer vorher noch Mirko Slomka holt für zehn Spiele und dann eben Christian Eichner? Was, Alternativlosigkeit, Verzweiflung? Gib uns mal einen Abriss.
Also Christian Eichner hat uns ja zu einem Zeitpunkt übernommen, wo wir einfach kurz vor dem Abstieg waren und hat uns dann gerettet. Ich glaube, wegen dem Torverhältnis damals, als Nürnberg dann in die Relegation gekommen ist. Und Christian Eichner war ja unter Alois Schwarz damals schon, sozusagen im Hintergrund tätig, war eine Art Co-Trainer, hat Alois Schwarz sehr viel begleitet, konnte damals dann auch schon sehr viel Erfahrung sammeln, was ihm, glaube ich, sehr zugute gekommen ist. Hat dann auch schon die Mannschaft kennengelernt, war vertraut mit der Mannschaft. Die Spieler haben ihn respektiert, auch wenn er jetzt vielleicht nicht der erfahrene Trainer war oder ja, Altersunterschied zu manchen Spielern ist jetzt bei uns auch nicht so wirklich gegeben. Aber man hat dann, glaube ich, einfach beim KSC gemerkt, okay, wie du schon angesprochen hast, kurz davor war Mikos Lomka noch Trainer. Es hat einfach nichts geklappt. Man war wirklich wieder kurz vor dem Abstieg. Man stand auch kurz vor der Insolvenz zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und ein Abstieg wäre halt wirklich einfach unser Ruin gewesen, sage ich mal so direkt. Und dann hat man sich vielleicht auch wirklich als letzte Hoffnung gedacht, okay, dann nehmen wir Christian Eichner und probieren es mit ihm. Machen wir mal was ganz anderes. Nehmen einfach keinen jemand wie Mikos Lomka beispielsweise, der zwar ein guter Trainer sein mag, aber einfach nichts mit uns als Verein zu tun hatte, komplett dann von außen kam und es einfach nicht gepasst hat, sondern hat wahrscheinlich wirklich gedacht, okay, wir haben nichts zu verlieren. Er wird respektiert. Er kennt die Mannschaft. Er ist da schon drin. Die Mannschaft muss sich nicht groß auf was Neues einstellen. Ja, und dann hat er uns, wie gesagt, zum Klassenerhalt geführt. Spektakulär fast schon. Und danach hatten wir eine wirklich gute Saison. Ja, jetzt haben wir auch wieder eine solide Saison im Mittelfeld. Also ja, wir haben uns stabilisiert. Manche, natürlich sprechen jetzt manche vom Aufstieg, wie jedes Jahr bei uns vor der Saison, aber das ist ja die typischen Flausen. Und ich sag auch selber, ich bin super zufrieden mit einem Mittelfeldplatz jetzt die letzten Jahre. Und dann kann man immer noch schauen, dass man was aufbaut im Verein, was ja auch immer jetzt geschieht. Stadionneubau ist ja das typische äußere Beispiel, was man sozusagen hat, dass der Verein jetzt wächst. Ja, und dann kann man am Ende einfach nur hoffen, dass es jetzt erstmal ruhig bei uns bleibt und man nicht wieder irgendwelche Turbulenzen plötzlich reinbekommt.
Der Wunsch, den viele haben, der Wunsch nach Ruhe. Jetzt haben wir viel über Christian Eichner gesprochen. Es gibt ja aber auch durchaus noch Spieler, die auch ihre Verantwortung dafür tragen, dass man eben jetzt eine dann relativ ruhige Saison hat und mutmaßlich eben das jetzt relativ in Ruhe auch noch zu Ende bekommt. Wer sind denn da für dich die entscheidenden Namen?
Ich glaube, das ist der Unterschiedspiel da teilweise auch bei uns. Gerade weil er vorne eben seine Tore schießt. Er macht aber auch die Bälle fest, aber hauptsächlich wegen seinen Toren und auch wegen seiner Präsenz auf dem Platz. Ich glaube, ohne Philipp Hofmann wird es ganz schwarz bei uns aussehen, ehrlich gesagt auch. Dass er immer das Thema dann bleibt, er geht, er was ja normal ist. Das ist so ein Thema, was auch ein bisschen Unruhe reinbringt, immer wieder in den Verein. Ja, dann ganz klar unser Torwart, Gersbeck, der hat uns schon so oft einfach den Arsch gerettet, sei es jetzt auch die erste Halbzeit beispielsweise gegen Auer, wo man sich dann wirklich einmal nur bedanken kann, dass es da noch 0-0 steht. Da haben wir wirklich einen Top-Torwart. Und meiner Meinung nach auch einfach Vanicek im Mittelfeld, der wirklich der Kreativmann ist, bei uns Ideengeber ist und auch wirklich mal ein Spiel entscheiden kann, den Unterschied machen kann. Und wen ich auch noch nennen möchte, ist Tim Breithaupt. Das ist ein ganz junger Spieler, noch gerade 20 Jahre alt geworden und ein Riesentalent einfach. Der wurde beispielsweise von Christian Eichner aufgebaut, mitten in die Mannschaft eingebaut, ist jetzt einfach ein fester Bestandteil von uns auf der Sechs. Und die vier Spieler sind bei mir so die Spieler, die ich diese Saison einfach als herausstechend bezeichnen kann.
Und wie würdest du den Spielstil des KSC bezeichnen oder beschreiben?
Schwierig. Ganz unterschiedlich. Also wir probieren wirklich offensiv zu spielen. Manchen spielen wir, probieren wirklich früh zu pressen. Dann gibt es aber auch andere Spiele, wo wir dann merken, okay, wir seiten uns vielleicht hinten rein. Ich finde, Christian Eichner passt sich sehr oft an den Gegner an und weiß auch, wie er die Mannschaft einzustellen hat auf die Gegner. Ich glaube, wir tun uns einfach schwer, wenn wir selber das Spiel manchmal machen müssen. Uns liegt es mehr, wenn wir sozusagen reagieren können auf den Gegner und dann beispielsweise pressen können, anstatt wenn wir merken, okay, wir haben viel Ballbesitz gegen unten stehende Mannschaften und müssen das Spiel selber machen. Das liegt uns einfach noch nicht. Da fehlt uns die Qualität vielleicht auch in der Hinsicht. Das merkt man auch einfach. Gegen Mannschaften unten sind wir nun mal wirklich, tun uns sehr schwer, haben Probleme, Spielaufbau, kreativ das Spiel zu gestalten. Und gegen Mannschaften, die wirklich selber das Spiel machen, wo wir dann, wie gesagt, reagieren können, ist es einfach viel leichter für uns, dann auch mal einen Kontakt zu setzen, einen langen Ball auf Hofmann einfach, ist, glaube ich, unser typisches Mittel, was dann meistens auch klappt dann. Der macht dann den Ball vorne fest und er ist halt nur mal einer der besten Stürmer in der 2. Liga, ich glaube, das kann man so sagen.
Ist das nicht interessant, Marco, dass wir hier zwei Mannschaften haben, die eben nur die Tordifferenz unterscheidet und dann ist es doch so unterschiedlich eigentlich auf allen Ebenen, über die wir bisher gesprochen haben?
Ja, also ich glaube auch, dass Karlsruhe und Paderborn grundsätzlich unterschiedlich sind, also sowohl von der Historie her, der KSC ja eher ein Urgestein des deutschen Fußballs, auch erstklassig gewesen, Paderborn eher so ein, ja viele sagen ja No Name, wobei ich glaube, dass Paderborn in den letzten 4, 5 Jahren mehr erreicht hat als so mancher Traditionsverein oder auch viele zusammen. Also es ist schon stark unterschiedlich, das sehe ich auch. Also mich wundert es auch ein bisschen, dass der KSC nicht den Anspruch hat, wieder weiter, also kurzfristig auch weiter oben mitzuspielen. Also ich meine, ihr wart ja schon mal kurz vorm Aufstieg. Redegation kann ich mich noch daran erinnern damals. Auch knapp raus, ich glaube gegen HSV war es. Wie siehst denn du das, Marie? Also hat man da Tendenzen, das zumindest mittelfristig wieder anzugehen, im Verein jetzt, also Umfelte ja immer aufsteigen?
Ja also ich glaube langfristig gesehen will man natürlich aufsteigen. Ich glaube, das ist das Ziel von jedem Verein, der auch schon mal bessere Zeiten hatte. Aber ich glaube, wie gesagt, aktuell ist einfach wirklich erstmal ein Grundstein legen. Ich meine gerade jetzt auch zum Sommer geht es einfach darum, bleibt Hofmann, geht Hofmann. Muss man erstmal schauen, was da passiert, findet man einen adäquaten Ersatz, findet man keinen adäquaten Ersatz. Und ja, wenn er jetzt sozusagen, wenn er bleiben würde oder man einen adäquaten Ersatz finden würde, dann könnte man meiner Meinung nach nächste Saison sowas wie einen Aufstieg oder oben mitzuspielen anpeilen, weil ich finde, der Kader ist von der Qualität her schon gut besetzt jetzt wieder. Aber ja, das ist halt, glaube ich, so der entscheidende Punkt erstmal bei uns. Wie gestaltet sich die Sommerpause? Welche Abgänge, welche Neuzugänge? Und was macht Philipp Hofmann einfach? Und wir sind schon sehr abhängig von diesem einen Spieler aktuell noch.
Und wie viel Vertrauen setzt du da in die sportliche Leitung? Also als Chefscout arbeitet Lothar Strelau beim KSC. Den kennen vielleicht auch noch so manche. Teammanager ist Burkhard Reich. Und ich weiß jetzt dann gar nicht, wer ist dann derjenige, der dann da die Entscheidung trifft in der sportlichen Leitung?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Okay, dann liegt es nicht an mir, dass ich das hier gerade auf der Homepage nicht gefunden habe in meiner Panik. Okay, was ist da los? Ist das jetzt ein Übergangszustand oder ist der KSC einfach so, dass er sagt, wir entscheiden das dann ja? Also im Aufsichtsrat muss alles abgesegnet werden, so wie es für mich jetzt aussieht. Also es gibt hier offenbar ja keine Hierarchie-Ebene zwischen Trainer und Aufsichtsrat. Es gibt einen technischen Leiter, Nechard Aigün, einen Chefscout Lothar Strehlau und noch einen weiteren Scout. Also wird es dann im Aufsichtsrat entschieden? Gibt es den klassischen Sportdirektor beim KSC einfach nicht?
Das weiß ich auch nicht. Aber ich glaube, beim KSC ist es inzwischen echt so, dass es wirklich viele können da sozusagen, es ist eigentlich eher so eine Gemeinschaft, dass wirklich dann geschaut wird, okay, was will halt auch der Trainer, ehrlich gesagt, und nicht einfach nur, das war beim KSC in den letzten Jahren auch ein großes Problem, dass einfach Spieler gekauft worden sind vom Sportdirektor, die einerseits gar nicht zu dem Spielstil des Trainers gepasst haben und auch einfach so nicht in die Mannschaft gepasst haben. Und ich glaube, daraus hat man dann auch viel gelernt, dass man wirklich bei der Kaderzusammensstellung und bei Neuzugängen schaut, was möchte der Trainer wirklich, was passt in seine Spielphilosophie, was braucht man, wo braucht man noch Unterstützung. Dass man wirklich eher so ein Miteinanderschaft und eine Gemeinschaft anstatt, dass man sagt, Oliver Kreuzer trifft jetzt als Sportdirektor einfach die Entscheidungen und schaut, wen er halt gerne hätte. Klar, hängt es halt auch viel mit Geld beim KSC zusammen. Ich meine, wir sind halt nur ein Verein, der hat jetzt nicht wirklich Geld.
Okay, das ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm. Das hätte ich durchaus wissen können, dass Oliver Kreuzer der Sportdirektor ist, seit 2016 schon und ist ja auch kein unbekannter Name.
Ich habe die Frage gerade auch gar nicht so ganz verstanden.
Ich war hier auf der Vereinsseite. Ich habe irgendwann gelernt, dass man sowas immer beim Verein nachgucken soll, damit man auch immer die korrekte Bezeichnung sagt. Weil dann ist jemand nicht Geschäftsführer, sondern Vorstandssport oder was auch immer. Ja und da, also entweder bin ich komplett blind oder meine Suche funktioniert nicht. Oder zumindest hier unter Profi-Fußball-Mitarbeiter steht er nicht mehr drin. Vielleicht ist er Profi-Fußball, was? Irgendwo anders. Aber gut, da wissen wir ja, Oliver Kreuzer trifft die Entscheidung. Geld ist definitiv immer ein Thema beim KSC. Das hat natürlich auch mit der jüngeren Vergangenheit zu tun. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel das Roh-Ergebnis anschaut, aus der Saison 2019, 2020, da lagen wir auf Platz 36 aller 38 Bundesligaclubs, die da in der ersten und der zweiten Männerbundesliga mit drin sind. Also deswegen 38, weil da noch zwei Vorjahre mit drin sind. Also da sind auch Absteige mit drin. Es ist kompliziert. Das ist auf jeden Fall relativ weit hinten. Und auch die Einnahmensituation ist dementsprechend der Personalaufwand auch sehr gering. Wie kann man denn da jetzt dann ein Stadion stemmen?
Ja, viel einfach durch Sponsoring. Und sonst muss man halt, also klar, wir sind jetzt ja kein eingetragener Verein mehr. Hat ja auch viel damit zu tun, dass man einfach damals geschaut hat, okay, als wir kurz vor der Insolvenz standen, wie kann man sich denn jetzt einfach retten und ja, im Endeffekt war es halt einfach wichtig, dann erstmal schnell Geld reinzubekommen. Man hat halt dann die Unterstützer gesucht, die dem Verein helfen. Und ja, das Stadion musste einfach neu gebaut werden. Das ist einfach nur mal eine Tatsache, so schön wie das alte Stadion war und so schön ich es auch gerne hatte. Ja, aber man muss beim KSC einfach immer noch jeden Cent umdrehen. Ich meine, gerade das Stadion belastet halt nun mal die finanzielle Situation noch weiter. Aber man plant da halt langfristig oder längerfristig und will halt den Verein dann auch äußerlich sozusagen dann neu aufbauen und modernisieren. Und er hofft sich dadurch dann auch weitere Einnahmen.
Okay, das heißt aber, es ist ja ein komplett neues Stadion, das gebaut wird. Der schöne Wildpark, den gibt es nicht mehr irgendwann. Oder ja, gut, es ist ja eigentlich jetzt alles so im Entstehen begriffen. Das wird dann aus Schulden, die man macht, finanziert, Sponsoring hast du genannt und muss so dann eben dann abgetragen werden über die nächsten Jahre. Na gut, anders geht es halt wahrscheinlich auch oft einfach nicht. Wie viele Jahre dauert es, bis wir den KSC in der ersten Liga wiedersehen? Okay, gut, ich hätte gedacht, du sagst vielleicht nie.
Ich habe gelernt im Sommer, ich sollte optimistischer denken. Und das habe ich mir für diese Saison vorgenommen. Deshalb sage ich mal drei Jahre.
Okay, wunderbar, sehr gut. Na ja, da freuen wir uns doch drauf. KSC einfach, ja, diese Mannschaften mit viel Tradition, wo man auch viele eigene Geschichten zu kennt, außer man vergisst halt, wer der Sportdirektor ist. Aber gut, das kann ja mal passieren. Das ist mir wirklich sehr unangenehm. Ich entschuldige mich nochmal. Ich versuche, meine Fehler einfach zu kaschieren, indem wir jetzt über unser Rostock reden. Wobei ich da jetzt ehrlich gesagt den Sportdirektor gerade auch nicht kenne. Meine Güte, bin ich Sportjournalist oder nicht? Es ist ja wirklich fürchterlich. Marco, rette mich, während ich jetzt google, wer der Sportdirektor von Hansa Rostock ist und sag mir, was wir über die wissen müssen. Die haben ja jetzt mit drei Siegen in Folge sich ein Pölsterchen erarbeiten können. Sechs Punkte Vorsprung auf Dynamo Dresden auf dem Relegationsplatz.
Ja, ich glaube, die haben sich aus dem Schalke-Spiel ziemlich viele positive Wipes mitgenommen. Und ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch erstaunt, gerade wenn man die Hinrunde so ein bisschen betrachtet hat, wo die ja so relativ weit unten rumgedümpelt sind und auch nicht so richtig in Tritt kamen, was daraus jetzt sich entwickelt hat. Also Jens Hertel hat da schon eine sehr schlagkräftige Truppe geschmiedet und hat seinen Spielstil auch sehr stark angepasst. Das verwundert mich sehr. Ich kenne Jens Hertel noch von seinen Tagen in Magdeburg, wo wir zusammen auch in der dritten Liga unterwegs waren. Ich habe da auch recht viel von mitbekommen. Ich finde, er hat sich so ein bisschen neu erfunden und spielt anders, spielt erfrischend. Vor allen Dingen passt das auch gut zu der Mannschaft. Ich finde, das ist jetzt in der Rückrunde so ein bisschen mit einer der Überraschungsmannschaften, würde ich sagen.
Kevin Meinhard ist der sportliche Leiter. Das habe ich inzwischen herausgefunden. Ja, das ging wahnsinnig schnell. Es ist mir wirklich unangenehm, aber ich bin sowieso so schlecht mit Namen und ich schaffe es leider nicht. Vorstandssport ist natürlich, um Gottes Willen, Martin Pickenhagen. Ach Mann, das ist ja Oliver Kreuzer Kategorie. Es ist wirklich peinlich.
Weißt du denn auch, wer Paderborn der Sportdirektor ist?
Mir fällt gerade nur Sami Arabi ein, aber das ist natürlich der falschestmögliche Name an dieser Stelle. Es tut mir leid. Die Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer sollen über mich richten. Marie, wie richtest du über Rostock? Hast du was zu dem ergänzt, was Marco gesagt hat?
Ich kann ihm da eigentlich nur zustimmen. Rostock ist der beste Aufsteiger. Bei denen hat man einfach nicht das Gefühl, dass die mal komplett einsacken, selbst wenn sie mal ein paar Spiele verlieren. Ich glaube einfach, dass die jetzt auch so gefestigt vielleicht sind durch den Trainer, dass sie einfach den Klassenerhalt eintüten werden und dann, glaube ich, auch einfach zufrieden sein werden.
Ja, ich glaube, damit kann man zufrieden sein, wenn man aufsteigt und sich dann in der Liga hält. Es ist schon wirklich interessant, allein die Träne, über die wir in diesem Kurzpass hier gesprochen haben, wie unterschiedlich sie sind. Quas New York-Eichener, jetzt dann eben mit Jens Härtel, jemanden, der eben auch sich sehr am Gegner orientiert, sehr gutes Ingame-Coaching hat, sehr oft auch die Formation wechselt. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, aber wenn man jetzt weiß, wie gut ich mich mit den Sportdirektoren auskenne in der 2. Männer Bundesliga, muss man das mit Vorsicht genießen. Aber manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, in der 2. Liga geschehen gerade auf der Trainerposition mehr Innovationen und mehr ein Hinwenden zum Modernen als in der 1. Bundesliga. Ich stelle das einfach mal so in den Raum. Das ist so mein Gefühl.
Du hast halt super viel Innovationsbedarf in der 2. Liga, um dich zu differenzieren, weil wenn du auch siehst, wie eng teilweise die Spiele zusammen sind, egal ob das jetzt ein Werder Bremen ist, ein HSV ist, oder ob das jetzt ein Nürnberg, Heidenheim oder auch ein Rostock ist. Ich glaube, man sagt ja vielfach, und das zeigt ja auch die Tabelle im großen Teil, bei der Hinrunde vielleicht noch viel mehr als jetzt gerade in der Rückrunde, die Teams liegen gar nicht so weit voneinander entfernt. Also jeder kann jeden schlagen, sagt man ja immer. Und man hat ja auch immer wieder einen Ausreißer drin, dass auf einmal ein vermeintlicher Favorit eine Schlappe einstecken muss. Und ich glaube, dass das auch ganz viel mit den Leuten auf der Bank zu tun hat. Also ich glaube, dass noch viel mehr Innovation auf der Bank, wie du es gerade auch schon gesagt hast, als in der ersten Liga. Auch notwendig, um sich zu differenzieren. Und vor allen Dingen hast du viele hungrige Trainer. Also das sind ja alles Leute, die das nicht als ihre Karriereende ansehen, würde ich mal so sagen, oder größtenteils, sagen wir es mal so.
Der umgedrehte Maggarteffekt in der 2. Bundesliga ist zu beobachten. Was können wir denn dann Marie über Holstein-Kiel festhalten? Auch da gab es ja einen viel diskutierten Trainerwechsel ohne Werner. Jetzt ist Marse Rapp da am Ruder. Holstein liegt gerade mit 34 Punkten Punkt, gleich mit Hansel Rostock dann eben auch 6 Punkte vor den Abstiegsrennen. Hatte jetzt aber wirklich eine schlechte Phase, die am Wochenende endlich durchbrochen werden konnte mit einem Sieg?
Ja, ich glaube bei Kiel ist es auch einfach so, dass sie in den letzten Jahren dann oftmals irgendwelche Abgänge zurückstecken mussten. Sei es jetzt auch letzte Saison mit dem Trainer, wie du den gerade angesprochen hast. Ich glaube, die mussten sich immer wieder ziemlich neu orientieren. Ja, ich bin immer wieder fasziniert, wenn ich mir aktuell den Kader anschaue. Ich habe mir jetzt mal kurz angeschaut, auch einfach. Dann haben sie Fiete Arb im Kader oder Reese, die oftmals einfach als Talente noch vor ein paar Jahren gehandelt wurden, aber dann doch nicht den Durchbruch geschafft haben. Ja, den wollte ich gerade erwähnen. Ich wollte mit den jungen Leuten anfangen. Dann haben sie aber daneben noch einen Louis Holtby dann plötzlich aus der Versenkung geholt. Ganz komisch, da hat auch jeder geschaut, was macht der jetzt plötzlich wieder noch? Ja, also ich glaube, die wollen auch einfach die Saison jetzt im Endeffekt einfach nur abschließen und dann neue Saison, neues Glück vielleicht.
Marco, wie siehst du die Lage bei Ki?
Ja, ähnlich. Ich glaube auch, dass die, ich glaube, die brauchen auch ein paar Punkte, um wirklich von unten wegzukommen, weil Dynamo Dresden ist ja jetzt nicht so weit weg, 28 zu 34. Aber ich glaube auch, dass die sich gut stabilisiert haben mit Marcel Rapp. Also das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Ich glaube, das tat dem Kader auch gut, dass Ono Werner im Endeffekt, ich glaube er hat ja aufgehört, hat ja sozusagen Abstand genommen von dem Amt. Ich glaube, das hat dem Kader auch gut getan. Ich glaube, der Kader ist nach wie vor im Unbruch. Also es sind ja viele ältere Herren dort auch unterwegs, Finn Bartels, Holpi. Ich glaube, der Arp verlässt auch nach Ende der Saison Kiel, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe. Ich glaube, es ist eine Mannschaft im Umbruch gerade. Wir haben jetzt zwei Saison, glaube ich, ziemlich aktiv oben mitgespielt, sind jetzt ein bisschen im Umbruch gerade. Ja, würde mich freuen, wenn die sich stabilisieren, weil ich war auch noch nie auswärts in Kiel, da möchte ich unbedingt mal hin.
Ja, ich bin ehrlich gesagt bei Kiel einfach nur gespannt, was die nächsten Wochen noch bringen. Denn wenn ich aufs Restprogramm gucke, da gibt es schon die Gefahr, finde ich, noch mal reinzurutschen. Und jetzt am Wochenende eben, das war der erste Sieg nach vier Niederlagen in Folge. Man spielt jetzt zunächst gegen Darmstadt, dann gegen Hamburg und dann gegen den direkten Abstiegskampf-Konkurrenten Dresden. Will jetzt nicht irgendwie das Schwarze an die Wand malen. Es geht aber dann auch nicht so arg wie besser weiter. Also Heidenheim, Werder, Nürnberg und dann noch Sandhausen ganz hinten raus. Kann auch sein, dass –also meinem Gefühl nach Ligen, Holstein –diese Begegnung vielleicht sogar manchmal besser. Da holt man sich dann einen überraschenden Punkt und manchmal vielleicht sogar einen Sieg gegen einen großen Namen. Aber nur auf dem Papier gesehen ist die Situation, also die Saison ist noch nicht vorbei. Während wir bei euren beiden Vereinen mit drei Punkten mehr da relativ entspannt waren, würde ich sagen, na, Rostock und Kiel, die sollten jetzt ihre Grundspannung da jetzt nicht komplett aufgeben. Sonst könnte das vielleicht enger werden.
Wobei es sich ja meistens gegen vermeintliche stärkere Gegner leichter spielt, als wenn du jetzt wie Kiel am Wochenende gegen Ingolstadt so ein –ja, wenn du gegen die Keller-Kinder spielst, dann ist es glaube ich immer ein bisschen schwieriger noch zu spielen und selbst das Spiel zu machen, als wenn du als Underdog in ein Spiel gegen HSV reingehst.
Als ich es gesagt habe, ist es mir selbst aufgefallen, dass das jetzt nicht so die Neuigkeit ist für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass es so ist. Aber das baut uns ja die Brücke zu eben genau jenem Ingolstadt. Das ist die letzte Mannschaft, über die wir noch sprechen wollen. Marie, ich glaube, da muss man nach der Grundspannung jetzt nicht mehr fragen. In 13 Punkte Rückstand, letzter Tabellenplatz. Wir haben darüber jetzt auch schon mehrfach gesprochen, hier in den Kurzpässen zur 2. Bundesliga. Das hat sich jetzt nicht ganz so überraschend entwickelt, würde ich sagen, auch für alle Ingolstädter, obwohl man ja durchaus noch so ein paar Dinge verändert hat. Wie gefällt dir denn der FCI, wenn du jetzt einfach mal so auf die letzten Wochen blickst?
Ja, also, ich kann mit Ingolstadt an sich… Also es gibt so Vereine in der Liga, mit denen ich eigentlich einfach nicht viel anfangen. Und Ingolstadt ist halt nun mal einfach so ein Verein. Ja, ich glaube, das Spannendste wird bei Ingolstadt jetzt einmal noch sein, ob sie vielleicht noch mal einen von den großen Ärgern können, die oben vielleicht mitspielen, sei es jetzt den HSV beispielsweise noch. Aber ja, ich glaube, die wissen selber eigentlich, dass sie abgestiegen sind, jetzt gerade auch mit dem Rückstand, den sie haben. Jetzt auch gerade nach der Niederlage gegen Kiel, wo sie vielleicht dann doch immer ein bisschen Hoffnung hatten. Aber ja, sie wissen es glaube ich selber einfach, dass es nicht mehr wirklich realistisch ist, dass noch die Liga halten werden.
Dementsprechend stellen sie ja auch ihren Kader auf. Viele Spieler aus der U23, viele aus der dritten Liga noch mit dabei. Also das wirkt auf mich so, Marco, vielleicht auch ein bisschen im Kontrast zum SC Paderborn damals, wie ein Drittligist, der den Aufstieg geschafft hat, der aber im Grunde weiter so ein bisschen als Drittligist in der zweiten Liga spielt.
Ich glaube, bei Ingolstadt ist der Drops gelutscht. Und ich glaube, das ist auch nochmal ein gutes Beispiel. Wir hatten ja vorhin über diese Trainer-Rotation bei Schalke gesprochen. Ich meine, schaut euch an, was bei Ingolstadt passiert ist dieses Jahr. Petsold, Schubert, Rehm. Und wenn du halt die Qualität dann nicht im Kader hast, dass ein Tirodde dir einfach die Siege schießt oder in Summe die Kaderqualität gut ist, stehst du dann halt bei so einer Rotation auch ganz weit unten. Wobei, ich bin da schon bei dir, also ich glaube, dass Ingolstadt von Anfang an nicht so aufgestellt war, dass sie irgendwie gesichert gegen den Klassenerhalt entgegen marschiert sind. Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der Tabellenverlauf war, aber ich glaube, dass man dort, ja, also schon von Anfang an arg um den Klassenerhalt bibbern musste.
Ja, es gab nur einen Spieltag, an dem man nicht auf einem der letzten drei Plätze lag. Das war am zweiten Spieltag.
Also, wenn man das zum Beispiel mit Dynamo Dresden vergleicht, ich glaube, Dresden hat sich da deutlich besser aufgestellt als Ingolstadt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es finanziell um Ingolstadt steht. Das ist ja auch, glaube ich, ein sehr stark sponsorigen, abhängiger Verein. Der, ja, aber ich glaube, genau, es geht in die dritte Liga und das ist auch gut so. Und es ist ja okay, wenn man jetzt an Reben festhält und sich versucht dann für die dritte Liga aufzustellen.
Ja, also Ingolstadt, du hast es ja angesprochen, mit einem Automobilhersteller in der eigenen Stadt, anders situiert als andere Vereine bei den Verbindlichkeiten, zum Beispiel auf Rang 2, der kompletten Profi-Verein. Also man hat eben eigentlich kaum Schulden, aber logischerweise ist der Etat, der Personalaufwand, das ist alles. Da ist man ganz weit hinten in der Tabelle, die man da aufstellen kann. Und das ist ja vielleicht auch sogar ganz wohltuend, dass es auch noch diese Vereine gibt, die zwar auch Finanzkapital hinter sich haben und dadurch einen Standortvorteil haben, der jetzt erstmal nichts mit sportlichen Dingen zu tun hat, die aber dann daraus nicht den Anspruch ableiten, jetzt müssen wir in die erste Liga oder weit in der zweiten Liga mitspielen, sondern sie haben sich so ihr eigenes Profil erarbeitet. Mit einer Jugendarbeit, auch mit einer spielerischen Ausrichtung hatten ja auch schon den ein oder anderen interessanten Trainer, der es von dort aus dann geschafft hat, in noch größere Weinen, höhere Weinen des Profi-Fußballs zu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist die Rolle von Ingolstadt. Da haben wir jetzt noch mal eine große Fass aufgemacht. Ganz am Schluss. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Das hat, wie immer, große Freude gemacht, mit euch über die zweite Bundesliga zu sprechen. Ich kann allen daraus nur empfehlen, euch zu folgen. Auf Twitter, Marie heißt da et Risixo. Risixo? Es ist wie Risico nur mit X. Meine Güte. Marie, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und danke ebenfalls an Marco Kornrumpf vom Padercast, der et MA Kornrumpf, auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Marco.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung und hat mir sehr viel Spaß mit euch beiden gemacht.
Das freut mich. Ich wünsche euch allen eine gute Zeit und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr nachschauen, wie man das tut und auch schon die kleinen Beträge helfen. Die summieren sich auf. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Es lohnt sich auch in den nächsten Tagen mal unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de reinzugucken. Da wird nämlich unsere neue Tasse veröffentlicht. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.